[Music]
brian
in flint michigan hey brian how are you
good how are you guys great how can ken
and i help today
well i'm kind of in a predicament here
um
i'm a diesel mechanic by trade um
sorry i'm a little nervous but uh that's
okay take your time
what i got going on is i'm kind of in a
toxic work environment
um i've got a job offer on the plate
and it's more per hour
but we're trying to get out of debt if
if i did my numbers right we'll be out
by march
with staying with my current job um i
work
60 hours a week if not more
so there's no no real home life and a
lamp this new job is no
overtime a straight 40 hours
but only two dollars an hour more
and the insurance is more expensive
benefits package isn't 100 there
i'm like like i said my current job it's
a lot of overtime a lot of you know
brian let me ask you this brian so i'm
assuming you called us and you've run
these numbers
and what i mean by numbers is have you
run the numbers on okay you got a two
dollar an hour bump
but it's back to 40 hours how does that
compare with the 60 hours you're putting
in now
uh with your current rate and then the
cost of the
uh the benefits going up and everything
so if you run the side by side between
current job and new offer
have you done that yeah if if i keep
the overtime and all that it's about
almost 30 000 a year
less to take the new job yeah and that's
where my
that's where my predicament is it's like
well
if i stay at this track i'm looking at
march we're looking at march to be out
of debt
well but but you also have to take into
consideration brian that you're freeing
up 20 hours in your week that you could
go take another part-time job do
something else that brings you joy
gets you out of this toxic environment
and you're still able to up your income
a little bit to maybe still stay on
track
okay that's a possibility i'm not you
know what i mean like that's one option
on the table
when you called us you gave us an either
or which way were you leaning before the
call started
you know uh i've been leaning both ways
it's like
do i stick it out just to make sure you
know make us
pick on our plan brian i probably
brian i want to know i know you've been
going both ways
but you were leaning one direction i
just know it which way were you leaning
before you called us
partially sticking with my my job
currently yeah and the reason is is
because you know
what you've got there you're working 60
hours
you keep this up and you can you can gut
it out you can keep it going it's not
fun
but march is going to be here before you
know it so my question is let's go to
the future
okay because i i think this is almost a
false choice for you
it's less about dropping back to 40
hours a week
okay and it's more about what's the
future look like
so let's fast forward to march you're
out of debt
okay and you've been working so hard and
let's say that you backed off the
overtime
what would you be wanting to do long
term do you want to stay as a diesel
mechanic or would you want to
move into something else or do we stay
as a diesel mechanic where we are or
diesel mechanics somewhere else what's
that look like
it's always been my passion to be a diva
mechanic great
um so are you thinking you're gonna drop
back on the hours
after we get out of debt in march i
would hope
i would hope to well wait a second what
do you mean what do you mean you hope to
or do you not have a choice right now
i i do have the choice to drop it back
or
continue pounding it pounding out the
hours
well but you're saying there's no home
life who's on the other end of that and
what do they feel about you staying at
60 hours a week
after we get out of debt i got a wife
and
daughter and they wife would like to see
me home
a lot more well i got to tell you
speaking as the resident husband on the
panel i would do that
i would be gazelle intense i think she's
probably on board with the 60 hours for
the reasons
but but i would then you know start to
drop back and maybe you know kind of
wean yourself off of the 60 hours
because you want to get to baby step 3
that emergency fund as well
but i would do that so i i got to tell
you
i wouldn't take the new job based on
what you're telling me christy you see
anything else there
you got anything else on that on no i
will say though i always
i don't like situations where i feel
painted in a corner with two bad options
bad option here is i'm taking a 30 000
pay cut bad option here as i'm staying
in a toxic work environment
i just encourage you um to look at other
options so brian you can stick this out
march will be here before you know it
this is not a if you were saying this is
three years from now
we'd be like okay let's assess a
different path to get there you staying
on this path
and be like hey we're gonna buckle down
for this season until march we got our
eye on the prize we're so close to the
finish line
you can do it and you will do it but
it's not
a bad thing if you want to explore what
it would look like to
fill those other 20 hours so you're not
home anymore but you may be happier
you may be earning income in those 20
hours that's an
option on the table but i think i think
ken's right you're the
low-hanging fruit the quickest win is to
stick with what you've got what you know
has good benefits has the income you
need and then in march you reevaluate
what you want to do
evaluate your pay evaluate your schedule
evaluate everything because you're
debt-free and you've got
some more margin and flexibility there
that you've worked so hard for yeah and
i and i i would lean into the toxic part
i think that's right i think i'm hearing
toxic thrown around a lot
i get it but but that is a very good
point
and and i do think that if it truly is
toxic
then diesel mechanics are always going
to be needed
whether it's diesel specific or just
your mechanical abilities are so
transferable
so in that situation brian now we're
looking for a different
different opportunity so you would be
doing what i call doing the right thing
in the wrong place if it truly is a
toxic environment i believe
that there's definitely some
difficulties there but you're just
looking for a different place
where whatever's going on in that
workplace is not happening
as much so i i'd sit tight and then
let's look to move on
after we get out of baby step two we
appreciate the trust and and appreciate
the call and that really is a tough
situation where
you're gazelle intense and you're going
good grief this is exhausting
it is it is and i think that's that's
the other thing too where it's like
you can buckle down for a season and we
all have to do that at times
but maybe there's maybe there's another
path there if not then you buckle down
for that season and when
march comes you open up your options